So what is bitcoin?
Bitcoin has been on a wild ride lately,...
...seemingly every day is bringing new highs.
Bitcoin is a digital network that allows two people to exchange value directly...
...between each other without any middlemen.
That sounds confusing. Just think of it as online cash.
This is a highly speculative asset right now.
This is a big bet on a new technology and that becomes very alluring to people.
But if you really want to invest in bitcoin at this point,...
...you basically have to buy it directly.
To do that, you need to go online, get yourself a bitcoin wallet,...
...find a bitcoin exchange...
...and put in a buy order.
But keep in mind, this is a small, volatile, largely unregulated...
...and still very highly speculative market.